this morning
three defendants were convicted of
committing federal hate crimes in
connection with the murdery the murder
of ahmad arboree
on february 23 2020
mr arbory was targeted
chased
shot
and killed
while running on a public street
today a jury of the defendant's peers
unanimously found beyond a reasonable
doubt
that the defendants acted because mr
arbory was black
the defendant's actions and the racism
that fueled them have inflicted enduring
trauma on mr arbory's family
his friends his community and
communities across the country
my heart goes out to his parents
ms wanda cooper jones and mr marcus
arbory senior
for the unimaginable loss
they have endured
upon its founding
after the civil war during
reconstruction
the justice department was tasked with
bringing to justice
those who use terror and violence to
prevent black americans from exercising
their civil rights
the white supremacists who carried out
those acts
assumed that they could operate outside
the bounds of the law
modern federal hate crime laws have
enhanced the justice department's
authority to prosecute violent acts
motivated by bias
throughout our history
and to this day
hate crimes have a singular impact
because of the terror and
fear that they inflict on entire
communities
the justice department does not
investigate or prosecute people because
of their ideology or the views they hold
no matter how vile
but the justice department does have the
authority and will not hesitate to act
when individuals commit violent acts
that are motivated by bias or hate
no one in this country should have to
fear the threat of hate-filled violence
no one should fear being attacked or
threatened because of what they look
like
where they are from
whom they love or how they worship
and no one should fear that if they go
out for a run
they will be targeted and killed because
of the color of their skin
the justice department has a legal
obligation to prosecute hate crimes
and as americans
all of us have a moral obligation to
combat the hatred and bigotry that
motivates those crimes
today's verdict makes clear that the
justice department will continue to use
every resource at its disposal to
confront unlawful acts of hate and to
hold accountable
those who perpetrate them
i want to thank the members of the civil
rights division the united states
attorney's office for the southern
district of georgia and the fbi for
their work on this case
i also want to thank the jurors for
their service
and the state authorities including the
georgia bureau of investigation
that assisted in this prosecution
although we welcome the jury's verdict
the only acceptable outcome in this
matter
would have been mr arbory returning
safely to his loved ones
two years ago his family and his friends
should be preparing to celebrate his
28th birthday later this spring
not mourning the second anniversary of
his death
tomorrow
ahmad arbory should be alive today
thank you
i'll take a few questions
general um if i may switch gears to
ukraine what can the department of
justice specifically do to help
divide administration
with this situation in ukraine then i
have a follow-up on ukraine
well as you know the justice department
has both law enforcement and
intelligence responsibilities and we are
members of the national security council
and that's all i can say about it right
and there are reports that there are
videos that are coming from that part of
the world that are fake that are
doctored does the justice department
have a responsibility to legally
investigate something that could change
the outcome
i mean you're briefed on some of this
stuff
look we have uh for many years expressed
concern about malign influence
and those kind of matters without
referring to them in specific and the
justice department does have a role but
that's all i can say for now
um wanda jones who you mentioned said at
a press conference after this verdict
that was in that essentially justice was
served because the family pushed in
court to have a judge reject this plea
deal that's the only reason justice was
served what's your response to that and
then on a sort of unrelated topic last
week the national
one question yeah let's start with that
thank you
on your first question
i i cannot imagine the pain that a
mother
feels
to have her son
run down and then gunned down
while taking a jog on a public street
my heart goes out to her and to the
family
that's really all i can say about this
i could ask an unrelated question
last week the national archives revealed
that it found classified information in
15 boxes of documents stored at
mar-a-lago is the justice department
investigating to determine how the how
that classified information got there
and who might have accessed it so as a
as the archivist said in a letter that
was sent to the congress uh the national
archives has informed the justice
department of this and communicated with
it
and we will do what we always do under
these circumstances
look at the facts and law and take it
from there
oh yeah hi thanks for doing this press
conference um
last july the justice department had a
uh there was a research report that went
out which said that over the past two
decades the doj has declined to
prosecute 82 percent of the people who
are suspected of hate crimes
why is this case today differently
you know why is what what does this case
say about
your path going forward why has it been
so difficult in the past to secure
convictions um and also you know do you
think now in hindsight that entering
into a plea in this case would have been
a mistake in light of today's victory
and i have one other question after that
that's a that's a three-fer um her
second one was just asked over here and
i'll
write down the same answer i gave on
that one
um
on
the first question look
um
every case is decided on its own merits
we've done a number of hate crimes
prosecutions already in the last two
years and we will continue
to bring those cases
where we have the facts and the law on
our side now you have a third question
um
does the justice department have any uh
concerns with just hypothetically
bringing charges against a former
president which has not been done before
is that is that something on the table
yeah so
a i don't answer hypotheticals and b i i
can't make any comments about
whether we have investigations or not
this is our standard practice
to not answer those kinds of questions
thanks everybody thank you
[Applause]
thank you sir thank you
do you want me to
change the responses
[Music]
no
um
okay
okay